Це звичайний німецький дитсадок при церкві.
Лише подія незвична: відомий на весь світ
швейцарський автор дитячих книжок Маркус Пфістер
читає малечі уривок зі своєї книжки.
Я найкрасивіша риба, я краща за всіх інших
і я не маю з ними разом грати.
Сюжети історій автора прості,
але з глибоким змістом.
Головна героїня його книжки - веселкова рибка -
ось уже 25 років стикається з різними
життєвими ситуаціями.
Зокрема і з питаннями толерантності.
Ставленням до приїжджих, до біженців тощо.
І не важливо, що аудиторія цих історій - діти до 6 років.
Я вважаю, що діти мають
якнайраніше дізнатись, що у світі
існують багато різних людей,
і як варто з ними взаємодіяти.
І що це нормально, що ми всі різні.
Але ми маємо навчитись мирно співіснувати одне з одним.
Це один з найстаріших книжкових магазинів
для дітей у Німеччині.
Зазвичай тут є щонайменше півсотні книжок
про толерантність. Ось, бачите, навіть
є тут окремий стенд. Постійний, до речі.
Зокрема, про толерантністьдо біженців,
до різних релігій та до різних родин.
От, наприклад, ця книжка -  про двох пінгвінів-гомосексуалів
та  іхню дитину. До речі,  ця історія реальна
і сталася у Нью-Йорку.
"Два тата для Танго ", "Деякі інші ", "Людство"
Тут ідеться про те, який вигляд мають
люди з різних частин світу.
"Усі різновиди родин","Я такий, а ти який?"
Книжка чітко пояснює, що нормально мати родину,
де є лише одна мама, і райдужну родину,
де дві мами або два тати.
Усі ці книжки лежать на видному місці,
їх ніхто не ховає подалі від очей.
І за понад 60 років існування книгарні
ніхто її не бойкотував і не погрожував
за продаж такої літератури.
Як це, наприклад, сталось в Україні у зв'язку з
презентацією першої дитячої книжки
про толерантність  "Майя та її мами".
Там, окрім іншого, розповідається про родину ЛГБТ.
Страхи певних ультраправих в Україні про те,
що такі видання можуть погано вплинути на дітей,
Каспер відкидає.
Це хибне уявлення, що,
прочитавши книжку, я вирішу стати геєм чи лесбійкою.
Адже це радше біологічний процес,
який відбувається без впливу ззовні.
Я думаю, ці книжки допомагають,
з одного боку, дітям приймати інших людей
такими, які вони є. А з іншого боку,
допомагають дітям або підліткам,
які є представниками ЛГБТ,
дізнатись із книжки, що це також є нормальним,
що не варто цього боятися.
На книжки про толератність у Німеччині є попит.
Їх включають до навчальних програм
у дитсадках і школах.
Щоб уникати скандалів і непорозумінь,
батькам слід також читати про толератність,
вважає письменник Маркус Пфістер.
Адже, на його думку, діти мають
значно менше фобій і проблем
у ставленні до чужинців та не таких, як вони,
людей, ніж дорослі.